health and human services secretary alex
azar submitted his official letter of
resignation overnight
in it he admonished the violence at the
capitol
as an assault on democracy azar's exit
effective wednesday follows the anger of
multiple governors who accuse the
federal government of deception
upon learning the national stockpile of
coronavirus vaccine
has been depleted it comes as the u.s is
in its deadliest week yet
of the pandemic more than 3 200 lives
were lost
every day so far more than 31 million
doses of vaccine have been delivered
across the country
just over 12 million doses have been
administered michael george reports
even lines of body bags in los angeles
don't show the worst of it the cdc
warned friday
the nationwide death toll is expected to
rise by more than 90 thousand
in the next three weeks bringing u.s
deaths close to half a million southern
california though
continued to be kovid's epicenter the
governor took to dodger stadium to
promote a large-scale vaccine
distribution plan
our result is to get all of the existing
doses that are in this state
administered as quickly and efficiently
as possible
but the state plans were put in another
bind after the federal government's
promise to unleash
vaccine reserves turned out not to be
viable
we were lied to with plans of the
administration to release
reserve doses colorado's governor jared
polis was among a chorus line of
governors
lashing back i am shocked and appalled
that the federal government would set an
expectation
with the american people on which they
knew they could not deliver
with such great consequences the news
broke
in the same week officials lowered the
age for those most in need of a vaccine
that's the mathematical problem that the
federal government created
we're going to make it open to 75 plus
we're going to make it open to 65
plus but and don't worry we'll increase
the supply
because we're going to send you the
second dose
not true but pfizer tells cbs news
operation warp speed has asked us to
start shipping second doses
only recently as a result we have on
hand
all the second doses of the previous
shipments to the u.s
the company says it's working around the
clock to produce millions of additional
doses
for cbs this morning saturday michael
george
new york